Michael Irvin is made here you could
just pull that microphone right in front
of you if you don't mind right there
okay Michael's in town for to be part of
a roundtable discussion tonight that I
will be hosting for the NFL 100 campaign
the 100th year professional football
kicking off in earnest one week from
Thursday night between the Packers and
the Bears and Kurt Warner will be here
in our number three because he's part of
the panel tonight Kyle Brant who's part
of the hosting of it from good morning
football he'll be here in our number
three and also part of the panel tonight
somebody that I do believe once bounced
Michael Irvin from the playoffs Barry
Sanders is about to make it here is that
true right
yeah I spent some time with Barry last
night - Barry's a funny dude man he's a
funny dude and yes they did
bounced us bounce us once from the past
now that was the last loss before before
the Super Bowl before the Super Bowl run
it was it was the prop up - God Almighty
we just we let Detroit beat us this will
never happen and won three Super Bowls
after that so we use them as a tailwind
cheap I was going through 38 6 January
5th 1990 what did Barry's doing that get
buried I mean he was I mean those
numbers in that game not that good 12
carries 69 yards and a touchdown right
right catches 30 yards and a night
that's the game Beuerlein started then
we went back to Troy Aaron arremer went
nuts for Detroit 341 yards three
touchdowns Erik Kramer hold on man Eric
crane will call it right there perps got
two phones here one of them's on then
I'm gonna air right and ID I gotta call
you back
so let's talk first let's talk first
about what everybody is talking about
over the weekend and you think I'm
referring to Andrew Luck's retirement
I'm talking about you firing up the
crowd where the turnover chain in Miami
and now here's your here's let me walk
everybody through this let me walk
everybody this video man hold on a
second this video that went viral
because Irv was firing up the crowd 5.7
million views right now okay I I saw it
my wife Susie were you know longer than
me right really we we were like what are
people so right this is Mike why are
people like what's going on with Mike I
mean that's Earth yeah I mean so I was
we work I was a couple of five points
some odd million views but I'm not like
you know saying that something's up for
me because that's just
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and by the way Reggie Reggie Wayne was
like me chill we're like Reggie's not
even reacting like yeah because we've
seen this before I wanted to put 325 on
my back after that oh my god it was so
crazy and what it was see I had like an
eight man crowd you can't start a pep
rally with an eight man crowd cuz you
just keep stepping up harder and if they
a minute you go higher then they a
minute I went all the way about say hey
we got crazy man but I knew rich when I
got in the car I was hitting home
afterwards and I saw those all of those
oh my god all them people watch oh now
if this thing doesn't go right they're
coming back because so many people you
know and all the Gator fans you know II
took it personally I didn't see anything
personally towards them I just said
we're gonna step on their throne in
watch out their heart that was a great
game and I know people are talking about
you know some sloppy sloppiness in the
game like missed tackles and and we're
you know some turnovers but I'd rather
have a game like that then play you know
mother poor school and it's a 5410 game
I know what I mean it was it was a great
game i really enjoyed the game even
though we didn't win I really enjoyed
that guy I also think it's great that
Miami in Florida want to play each other
period number one and then but first
does gate yes first out of the gate
right we're asking that Michigan in a
Notre Dame used to play first out of the
gate every year was a firt last year was
one of the first times in a very long
time there and and then Notre Dame
started to warm up for Michigan and we'd
put it what you call what's the name of
the team the Mary's sister or whatever
you call them like that right so but I
think that's great like you know let's
put a chill on the line right out of the
gate and obviously not everybody's gonna
go undefeated for the year me too it's
gorgeous and just on that note when I
was gonna college gameday next morning I
did pick Michigan they went to win the
conference is your without Urban Meyer
over there at Ohio State you know III do
you think this is hard balls year you
know I do okay I'll take you on that I
hope that's actually the cake from your
lips to the Godsey and football gods
Michael Irvin here on the Rich Eisen
show right now now your thoughts on
Andrew Luck stunning retirement Barry
Sanders gonna be here shortly obviously
he's got some perspective on retiring
early what do you think of you know what
blew my mind when I watch it when I
watch it as a while and all of us all of
us have some culpability here in and
being guilty because you remember how
many times on the shows did we talk
about when these guys came out Andrew
Luck Cam Newton I'm I need some big guys
you know they could handle pounding
they're being the big quarterbacks all
great arms they can run the budding
handle pounding we put our mouths upon
their worlds we were we were wrong
nobody can handle this pounding not even
those guys man and and and and I was
shocked I was shocked you know that he
decided to walk away from from the game
I'm just absolutely shocked I thought
maybe you know maybe maybe he wants to
title the time away I'll take a little
time away but Andrew Luck said he just
can't take it anymore and people don't
understand it said the two things you
gotta do when you're a football player
and you're committed to guys like that
it's the worse things in the world I may
have told you this before it's to be
injured while the rest your guys out
there playing you feel so just it's just
so so isolated and not a part of it you
know it wears on you so much so I could
imagine how much it wears on him and and
and it's just too much is too much
mentally more than physically you know
it for him so so I wish him the best man
I wish me best I hate that we're losing
them what about the idea again to give
fans a better idea cuz Gronk said the
same darn thing this morning I don't
know if you heard Gronk spoke today I
had a press conference because he's
joining up with a company that makes CBD
to have CBD products for pain relief
being used by NFL players
he said his guys retired boy and he's
just going that I'm smoking weed hunt
there's no change in CBD though sure it
ain't okay but he said but he no he said
here hold on that that the injuries the
injuries that he could barely walk after
he was done with the game he slept for
five minutes than I are the Super Bowl
when tears in coming down his face in
bed not of joy but in pain and saying
that I was losing that joy in life Luck
said the same thing about how the
injuries and the rehab and then the
constant concern about trying to get
back was sucking the joy out of the game
can you relate to that at all rich right
yeah you know from their perspective you
know I was a guy with a broken neck
trying to run their every doctor to say
that define one doctor that says you can
still play you know me so so so you know
I just love the game and wanted to be
around it and everything but but as we
talked about it this game if the guys
are bigger the faster they're stronger
now and they're running into each other
so so yeah I can relate to them wanting
to walk away but that being said I would
I would do anything still to this day
still to this day to get out on that
football field and play as difficult as
it is and this pain for it is is my love
for it is that great so so I understand
those guys they've had great success and
and they're walking away but but but
yeah I would do anything to keep playing
well you're a fan as much as anything
else we just saw that obviously from yes
this weekend in Miami could you
understand why some fans would have
booed Andrew Luck coming off the field
on slow after the news broke well you
know I well if you look at it from the
standpoint of honestly you know a lot of
people had the coach just a year coming
in and and and a lot of those fans
probably went and bought bought those
season tickets and we got a shot we're
going to Super Bowl this year we're
going to Super Bowl and when Andrew Luck
made that announcement that investment
we're down the drain right down the
drain so you know
I guess from their disappointment and
they're they're hurting their pain
that's how they voiced it you know IIIi
stay away from calling somebody
classless or anything when they do stuff
like that I'm sorry man it's just people
just actually giant that's our that's
our fearless leader stop messing around
probably he's probably watching right
now he's not that's the point that's the
point Michael okay there may be an eye
and Michael and but there's one in rich
and Eisen and this is about me I cannot
wait and just understand Michaels busy
in the middle of but I thought a very
cogent point about about fan bases and
things of that name right right right
but my friends my friends when they see
me on game day morning they see me and
then they'll start calling and I look
down you keep calling me you know I'm on
air why do you I just want to see you
look for my phone call so I thought
giant may have part taking it a little
bit I don't think so right there use his
phone called it to pivot real quick
before we take our first break here and
Barry Sandra's gonna join us in a second
if you're on hold stand hold will take
your calls to Kant per set go on a run
for the ages here I mean Frank Reich in
his career is presented in an incredible
at this man worries round ych ecobee
percent I was just mentioning about some
some good news in regards to the
Indianapolis Colts and I'll just say it
right here because I was teasing it in
the last hour is that returning to
practice is this speed burning rookie
from Ohio State Parrish Campbell he's
returned to practice T why Hilton those
two tight ends Devin Funchess from the
University of Michigan to be fair and
balanced at the Paris Campbell News I
mean why who said he wakes up Quran
just to hit the thought of what has
happened okay some cry is a pity does
well maybe because they're so tight with
Andrew Luck right right / said it that
this is all everything that lost because
of him not a great one of the great
stories we've seen rich that's why I
love this game so much and just me it's
Frank Wright leading this group yeah
it's Frank Wright the ultimate backup
quarterback come back and get you at
Buffalo come back and get you at
Maryland this is not this is something
that he's used to leading these new
courses incredible score tritak fries
it's incredible it's incredible but
Andrew Luck was the most gifted and the
best thing to come out at the
quarterback position since we invented
sliced bread and and and the leave the
loose sliced bread like that that's a
big heart that's a big heart fault now
and and and I hope the best of Jacoby
burr set but but that's the big heart
fall all right let's take a break here
Michael Irvin here on the Rich Eisen
show he's part of the NFL 100 campaign
tonight that's launching we're gonna
have a nice nice affair up there in
Lincoln Center around the city Barry
Sanders will be part of that as well but
before that he will join us here in
studio for more of the Rich Eisen show
tune - audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
for free on be our live or download the
Rich Eisen show app